I have been a police officer for a very
very long time and you see these notes
in my hand because I'm also a black
preacher if you know anything about
black preachers will close and they will
keep going for another 20 minutes a man
so I need this to keep pushing this
thing forward so I've been a police
officer for a very very long time and I
mean I predated technology I'm talking
about before pagers laughs if you want
to go I'm telling the truth I predate
war on our fellow man I mean war on
drugs I predate all that I predate so
much and I've been through evidence lows
and I've been through good and bad times
and and still I absolutely love being a
police officer I love being a police
officer because there's always been a
calling for me and never a job and even
with that my personal truth is that law
enforcement is in a crisis it's in a
visible crisis and it has been for many
many years even though we in law
enforcement say you know what
we can't arrest our way out of this
we're saying law enforcement things like
yes illegal to profile and you know what
in law enforcement we even agree that we
have to adopt this thing and become more
oriented to community policing and yet
all the while still we continue in the
same vein the same thing that
contradicts everything that we just
admitted and so that's the reason for me
several years ago because I was tired of
the racism I was tired of discrimination
I was tired of the isms and the schisms
I was just so tired I was tired of the
vicious cycle and I was tired of it even
in a beloved agency in the department
that I still love today and so my wife
and I we sat down and we decided and we
targeted date that we will retire we
were retiring I will go out for two to
sunset maybe do ministry for
time's love my wife a long time y'all
know what I'm talking about but we
decided that I will retire but then
there was a higher power than I there
was a love for the city that I loved
that I grew up in that I was educated in
a city that pulled my heart back into
the system so we didn't retire we didn't
retire and so what happened was over the
next couple of I will say 18 months 19
months I had this passion to implement
some radical policing and so now on over
the next 19 months I shifted and I
transcended from being a drug sergeant
ready to retire as a drug sergeant and
went from level to level to level until
I find myself as a district commander
district commander of the worst district
in Baltimore City we call it the Eastern
District the most violent district the
most perverse district 46 percent
unemployment in that district national
rating at that time national rating to
age that a tuberculosis was always on
the top ten list for zip codes for
cities across the nation or just zip
codes across the nation the top ten
I didn't say state I didn't say city
that little neighborhood and I said you
know what we got to do something
different we got to do something
different we got to figure a tackle we
got to think outside the box and so in
order to bring change that I desperately
wanted and I desperately felt in my
heart I had to start listening to that
inner spirit I had to start listening to
that man on the inside I went against
everything that had been trained to do
but we still did it we still did it
because we listen to that inner spirit
because I realized this if I was to see
real police reform in the communities
that I had authority over for Public
Safety and so we had a change I was
thinking thinking we had to change it
and so what we did is we started to
think holistically and not paramilitary
so we thought differently and we started
to realize that it could never be and
never should have been us versus them
and so
decided to come to that intersection
where I could meet all classes all races
all Creed's all color where I would meet
the businesses and I will reach meet the
faith-based and I would meet the edge
the meds and I would meet all people
that made up the communities that I had
authority over and so I met them and I
began to listen see police have a
problem all the time we want to bring
things into the community we want to
come up with these extravagant
strategies and deployments but we never
talk to the community about them and we
shove them into the community say take
that but we said we got to get rid of
that stinking thinking and so we started
talking to our communities and said you
know what this is your community table
we're gonna pull up a chair and we want
to hear from you what's going to work in
your community and there's some great
things started to happen so here's the
thing I had to figure out a way to shift
a hundred and thirty cops that were
under my tutelage from being occupiers
of communities to being partners I had
to figure out how to do that because
here's the clear the crazy thing in law
enforcement we had evolved into
something incredible listen we have
become great protectors we know how to
protect you but we have exercised that
arm so much so very much it's if I was a
natural police department and I
represented a police department you will
see this incredible beautiful 23 inch
armed man it's pretty ain't it's cut up
no fat on its own little good it just
look good that's a great arm protection
that's who we are but with exercises so
much sometimes that it has led to abuse
it's led to coldness and callous and
dehumanized us and we forgotten dementia
across this nation is to protect and
serve something y'all don't know that
protect this earth so you look at the
other arm and then you look at it and
there it is
you know it's kind of its kind of it's
kind of weak it looks sickly it's
withering and is dying because we've
invested so much in our protective arm
but we forgot to treat our communities
like they're our customers like they're
our sons and our daughters our brothers
and our sisters our mothers and our
fathers and so somehow along the way
somehow along the way we've gotten out
of balance and because we are proud
profession it is very hard for us to
look in the mirror and see our mistakes
it's even harder to make a change and so
as I try to hope and get through this I
need to say this it's not just a law
enforcement though because every one of
us makes up a community everybody makes
up a community and as communities can I
say this we have put too much
responsibility on law enforcement too
much
and then we have the audacity in a nerve
to get upset with law enforcement when
we take action there's no way in the
world that we as a community should be
calling the police
for kids playing ball in the street no
way in the world that we should be
calling the police because my neighbor's
musics of too loud because his dog came
over to my god and did a number two and
a number one there's no way we should be
calling the police
but we have surrendered so much of our
responsibility so much of the listen
when I was a little boy coming up in
Baltimore and listen we played rough in
the street I ain't never seen a police
come and break us up you know who came
in was the elders there was the parental
figures in the community
it was those guardians it was that
village mentality they came and said
stop that and do this and stop that we
had mentors throughout all of the
community so it takes all of us all of
us and I even listen I even and when I
say community I'm talking about
everything that makes up the community
even listen because I'm a preacher I
listen I'm very hard on the churches
because I believe the church is too
often have become mi a missing in action
I believe they have shifted over the
last 10 20 years from being community
churches when you walk outside your door
around the corner and you're in church
they shifted from that and they became
commuter churches and so you now have
churches who have become disconnected by
default from the very community where
they're planted and they don't take care
of that community I could go on and on
but I really need to wrap this up
community and policing we've all lost
that precious gift and I call it
relational equity we've lost it with one
another it's not somebody else's fault
it's all of our fault we all take
responsibility in this but I say this
it's not too late for all of us to build
our cities and his nation to make it
great again it is never too late it is
never too late you see after three years
of my four and a half year command ship
in that district 3 years in after
putting pastors in the car with my
police because I knew there's just a
little secret because I knew this it was
hard to stay a nasty police officer
while you're riding around with a clergy
now you'd be getting it out of the car
looking to your rights on my father
forgive me for I've seen all day long
you can't do it you can't to it so we
became up with some incredible
initiatives engagements for our
community and police to build that trust
back we began to deal with our youth we
began to deal with those who we consider
on the wrong side offense we knew that
we had an economic problem so we began
to create jobs we knew that there were
sickness in our community and they
didn't have access to proper Medicare so
we partner up we got to that
intersection we partner up with anybody
at one department with us and talked
about what we needed holistically never
thinking about the crime because at the
end of the day if we took care of the
needs of the people if we got to the
root cause the crime will take care of
itself
it will take care of itself
and so after three years of a four and a
half year stint we look back and we
looked over and found out that we were
at a 40-year historical low our crime
numbers our homicides everything I've
dropped down back to the 1970s and it
might go back further but the problem is
we only started keeping data since 1970
40 year crime law so much so I had other
commanders call me email what you doing
man what you're doing what you're doing
we got you some of that we got get some
of that and so we gave him some of that
and in a short period of time the city
went to a 30-year Crom low for the first
time in 30 years we fell Baltimore City
under 200 homicides 197 to be exact and
we celebrated because we had learned to
become great servers become great
service first but I got to tell you this
these last few years as much as we have
learned to become great proactive police
officers and great relationally police
officers rather than reactive these last
year's have disappointed me they have
broken my heart
the uprising still hurts it still hurts
my heart because truly I believe that it
should have never happened I believe it
should have never happened if we were
allowed to continue along the vein that
we were in servicing our community
treating them like human beings treating
them respect
loving on them first if we continue that
vein it would have never happened but
somehow we went back to business as
usual but I'm excited again I'm excited
again because now we have a police
commissioner who not only talked about
community policing but he absolutely
understands it and more importantly he
embraces it so I'm very excited now
listen I'm excited about Baltimore today
because we as many cities I believe
shall rise from the ashes
I believe I truly believe that we will
be great again I believe as we continue
to wrap arms and continue to say we're
inners together because it's just not an
intersection once we meet we now got to
get on the same
path for the same goals and this city
will become great again this nation will
become a great again because we have the
same goal we all want peace we all want
respect from one another we all want
love and I believe we're back on that
road and I'm so excited about it so
listen I thank you for give me a few
minutes of your time god bless you all
god bless you